we got you guys around though for
another demo absolutely actually on the
verge Thomas this is your project you've
been working on at telus tell us all
about it so yeah axiom verge is it's
like you said it's my my own project it
started off as a hobby about five years
ago I just had the urge to make you know
a game that would combine all the
aspects of my favorite games so it's
basically an action-adventure or
Metroidvania if you will um you know
fairly lengthy where you explore
labyrinth in world and collect items and
go back to previous places to figure out
how you know they're going to work and
allow you to bypass obstacles excellent
let's let's hop into right now the
controller doesn't seem to want to work
oh look at will get one of our technical
at monkeys to hop in a live TV oh no
that's I this is life isn't live is it
I've been scratching my nuts all morning
oh god I've been fired already and but
you but you work at a studio yourself
right this is like a pet project you're
working on the side is all right uh it
it was yes so for many years I worked
for petroglyph games yeah making RTS
games like the recently launched grey
gregorio and this was something i just
did after work or on the weekend or
whatever and it was like that for I'll
say about four years Wow and then um
after trying to promote the game and you
know going to indicate a meeting with
Sony it eventually got picked up by
their pub fund program all right so that
let me basically switch off and start
working on this full-time excellent
rather than as a hobby is that it was a
much more satisfying type of project to
do to be able to like work on something
for your own because presumably a
petroglyph you were one part of a much
wider machine yeah yes so there you know
I was an engineer on a team that would
vary in size from like 50 to 100 based
on if it was on the kind of game or yeah
what we were working on um and you know
that's actually very rewarding that
you know it's an awesome thing to do you
know for for your 40 hour week but yeah
this is definitely it's better to work
on your own thing for sure you get to
decide what you're going to do you know
how it's going to look so excellent ah
Eric tay our man on the street here is
plugging in USB controllers like it's
going out of business that he's done it
hey now we marry kiss easily got perfect
work don't worry best thing is we'll
just yeah we yeah we just hop straight
into it now if you do we want actually
average yes please tell me all about is
the word Metroidvania gets thrown around
quite a lot at the moment and you're in
that sort of realm yeah so I would say
when I first started this there wasn't
this Metroidvania Renaissance going on
because that was five years ago and a
lot of changes in that time so you know
I didn't I wasn't sitting there like oh
I got to get out on this dis
Metroidvania fad yeah that's the thing
now I was totally just thinking I want
to have fun yeah and you know it it
turned out to be the zeitgeist I guess
in the moment so that worked out but
you've been with giving this game a lot
of TLC and as opposed to a lot of other
games which you've been sort of catching
on to this and what about accion vers do
you think is like sets it apart from
from other games in this sort of weird
subgenres um we created so you know
first of all I really just tried to make
it a good action exploration type of
game um and that's that's the most
important thing then on top of that I
started layering some meta elements
there's the the glitchy element if um
where you you can glitch enemies and
each enemy will have a kind of different
reaction your glitching so they might
once they're glitched be able to heal
you or they might be able to break
through a wall or you know do a variety
of other things um and so that's in
there that's i would say kind of
integrated into your action exploration
one of the things i love about this the
first time i say that we've been seeing
it for a long time now is the art side
is just tremendous it's incredible
gorgeous thank you very much tell us
what the sort of the impetus for this
was were you trying to hark back to like
8-bit 16-bit brother or was was this
sort of like what you could do with in
you're means as a world like the you
have another artist work Thomas are we
doing yourself no it's it's it's all by
me um and I would say I'm actually
despite having been a programmer i was
actually trained as an animator so
really even even before I was you know
programming strategy games I was a 3d
animator um so I worked on like NFL
street and tiger woods and uh you know
sort of other games crash nitro kart I
can see we pulled your influences in for
October okay so you know this is more
like doing the thing that I thought
would be fun for me to do exilim nailing
down the specific art style kind of it
involved a few months of basically
putting together giant PSD's I would do
stuff like take screen captures of
various old 8-bit games i really liked
rygar and batman for the nests and
bionic commando shatterhand and i would
actually put screenshots like next to
each other already and kind of like
build you know a foe like world just out
of element just a little just to kind of
decide how i thought that it should look
in the end and so it eventually kind of
settled down on under this where you
have the discrete blocks rather than a
continuous environment mmm um and that
was you know came about organically I'd
say as I was putting things together am
i yeah I guess that's a wonderful thing
about working on a project over so many
years that you can allow yourself to
take the time to let those ideas sort of
gestate and manifest and yes and so tell
us about the sort of am I guess the the
progression of this is this again where
you're going to be playing for like a
number of arrow straight through is
there roguelike elements to it like
what's going to be likely pick up axiom
verge for the first time um so for the
first time it's the in terms of like
overall meta progression like the
overall map layout it's very much like
super metroid or symphony of the night
that kind of thing it's it's a it's a
large map the game is fairly long people
have been taking a you know between 10
and like 16 hours to complete the game
um the first time and that's that's if
you x
floor I think you'd probably you know
maybe your first time you might take
eight hours if you really don't explore
um and if you try to a hundred percent
it that's going to take you much longer
obviously so is the type of thing where
you're unlocking new abilities and going
back into older areas and then finding
like yes going through your gates and
whatnot yeah and you'd asked about road
like elements so this isn't this isn't
quite like chasm where the entire game
is come is roguelike but there are some
areas that will change for each
playthrough wow it's an optional kind of
side area where there's some additional
items and weapons that you can find that
won't be the same the next time you play
through and so that you know it's minor
it's I'd say about fifteen percent of
the game map it's going to be those so
that's an element that you're going to
keep meeting over and over again right
that's fantastic what in terms of
difficulty where do you lie with this
because you can kind of you can you can
go on either side of the scale with a
game like this especially with that type
of length can make it quite easy
experience for people just a bound
through or you can you know go super
crazy Super Meat Boy style making
impossible I would say there's two
difficulty levels there's normal and
there's the hard the normal is um it's
out I call it pretty like average you
know it's not dark souls um level
difficulty but it's also not super easy
uh you know part of it is because the
game is quite long so you don't want to
have the game be really long and be too
difficult normal setting the hard
setting I went about that by making the
game too hard for me to beat and then
scaling it back you know in increments
until I could beat it yeah so um I I
expect there's going to be people
definitely that say this is way too easy
even on card um but I think for the
casual gamer it's going to come out to
you know the typical gamer will find
this is pretty difficult but hopefully
manageable once they've gotten it down
yeah I tell us a bit about some of the
narrative stuff that's happening in this
as well so yeah there there is a
backstory it's
you know involves this character is a
scientist and he suffers this
cataclysmic accident in his lab mm-hmm
after which he wakes up in the strange
world you're you're looking at right
pretty strange this thing right here is
pretty strange so you know much of the
fiction is all about discovering this
world trying to figure out why he's here
what are these monsters that are you
know dropping bombs on him and basically
what's going on so it's it's a bit like
a mystery in that regard are you
expecting people to do multiple
playthroughs of this you know the game
that's 10 to 16 hours it seems like it's
not really requirement but are there any
elements of like new game+ stuff or do
you think that people will on like enjoy
second playthroughs once they figured
out the sort of the wider loop of the
game I think definitely there's um
there's a new place new game plus per se
there's the hard mode there's also a
speed run mode which is purely for the
you know competitive gamer or for the
gamer that doesn't you know care for the
story you know there's there's kind of a
tradition in Metroidvania games that
that the story is told by the visuals so
right you're you're not into dialogue
you put in that mode it will skip by any
cutscenes wow that those won't be
included in your timer and you get an
on-screen HUD showing you how fast
you're going that got a thing so and and
with that mode that's all about figure
out the fastest way to go there's a lot
of places where you know you can bypass
an item and it might actually be faster
if you don't get it or you know you
might find that that item you know bites
virtue of its powers makes things easier
yeah so you know i'm i'm expecting that
there's going to be replayability in
terms of that that's going to be a fun
experience for you and when it's it's
that pretty soon right it said like yeah
it comes out march 31st Wow ps4 and
you're looking forward to watching
presumably streams of people just
playing it and figuring stuff out yeah I
can't wait on the the ps4 share feature
is was kind of like a godsend yes kind
of game because if you know most of the
the competition's they feature Super
Metroid and players that have just like
master every nuance of that game and
when you know when I see those like the
awesome games done quick competitions i
always dream like that would be so great
if it was my game that that people were
playing so I tried my best to facilitate
that that's actually do you think that
might have had changed my elements of
your design as you're you're playing
with it um just like appealing to that
audience because that's kind of it again
five years ago there weren't all of
these people streaming games and
certainly not on console head and there
are some things i did i'm lucky enough
to have an acquaintance with a
speedrunner in las vegas who's he's
actually a shovel knight speedrunner but
he's I you know I said like can you you
know take a look at my game and like
give me some thoughts and he said like
okay yeah from like a speedrunners
perspective you know a good thing to do
would be to like make it more clear
which enemies are going to drop more
health right it's better if it's
established that this one kind of enemy
always gets more health because the
other ones you know a speedrunner might
actually just jump right through the
enemy take the damage because it's
faster yes you get to the other side
taking a hit than it is to trying to
kill it yeah um so there's there's a lot
of nuance like that that in my first
initial iteration of the game I mean I
didn't consider but then afterwards it's
like okay that you know that makes sense
so it's great it's good to have a
speedrunner in your pocket yeah and
thank you so much for coming in and
showing us axiom verge as you said it's
our 31st of this month on playstation 4
and it's coming over to other platforms
is there going to be via the cross
playing on that sort of stuff yes so
yeah the davita unfortunately is going
to be coming later but it will be coming
and that will be crossed by yeah so when
axiom verge comes out on the 31st it's
going to be part of a for PlayStation
Plus gamers it'll be ten percent off
right so you can get your Vita version
ten percent off by getting it then
excellent um and then when you cross
save cross save we are not sure yet okay
that's across your fingers yes there's a
big Vita ps4 fine I'll be right if you
get that done that'll be I want to do
that too yes so it hopefully there will
be a patch for the ps4 once i have the
vita
now and I know how it works I can get
them you know cross compatible that way
but I thought so yeah end of the month
fantastic
you